coupe cyberpunk fluo zombies ils jouent
leur rock'n'roll électronique avec de la
peinture fluorescente sur le corps et
seront en concert notamment le 22
février à la batterie à guyancourt avec
très peu n'aime pas lé voici pichot self
dans le kiosque
ah oui
commandé par ce qu'ils feront
d'expliquer que ce qu'on fait
généralement lit pour faire du rock avec
des grosses guitares et des grosses
machines voilà et en spectacle en plus
peut-être ça qui rend les choses plus
compliquées
c'est sûr que les bérus a été une
enflure ne savent pas forcément
musicalement enfin on avait 14 ans au
moment
où les bérets et béru explosé enfin tous
les sens du terme au moment où ils
s'arrêtaient devenir gros gros de la
vague donc ça ça nous a marqués
peut-être pas peut-être musicalement
sur sur certains points mais ça reste ça
reste la référence en compte le fait
d'avoir tout ce bordel sur scène ouais
ministry l'industrie ça a été
certaines grosses claques à l'époque ans
une jeune aussi puis après ça va dit guy
pop d'iggy pop
donna summer quoi donc
on a commencé par de la musique assez
laborieuse où d'ailleurs mes mails eu
l'idée de faire des trucs un peu plus
spectaculaires ou du visuel est venue
assez vite notamment pour pallier notre
en capacité et n'y ait plus de trois
accords de deux mamans desbuquois on
écoutait beaucoup de groupes de groupes
anglais assez assez spectaculaire à
l'époque aussi vraie comédienne sexy
boys on avait envie moi aussi de faire
des trucs comme on avait un bassiste à
l'époque ça a été notre dernier bassiste
d'ailleurs et qu'il y avait
voler des néons fait deux ou trois néons
sur un chantier en chantier dans une
boîte de nuit en réflexion il était
parti avec et il avait débarqué
aujourd'hui concernant tiens on devrait
s'y remettre ça et est devenu lui même
dû stabilo on va voir ce que ça donne et
on l'a compris ce jour là que notre vie
avait changé
elle aimerait entraîner dans le milieu
gay middle west à l'époque était
beaucoup plus drôle que maintenant que
le côté torture tristesse tout ça ça
c'est un épiphénomène qui m'avait
réception président dessus mais à
l'époque ce n'était jamais que qu'une
une excroissance du mouvement du
mouvement punk
donc on était avant tout là pour faire
la flatter effectivement la fête c'est
c'est aussi halloween quoi donc tout ce
folklore des sorcières des ventes qui de
tout ce qu'on veut quand il fait ça quoi
mais on n'a jamais été très premier
degré à ce niveau que genre gothisme
et s'est déchiré les veines sur les
falaises tout ça
c'était toujours plutôt le côté crampes
de la chose c'est à dire la fête des
monstres sans force pas d'avoir dans ce
qu'on fait des
les choses qui peuvent être auto plus
dérangeante plus vraiment sombre oui
mais mais toujours pouvoir dans un cadre
toujours dans son cadre oui au festif
même silence festif et populaire festif
sa fourrure enfants de dire festif
aussi bien par un reportage à la télé
sur un type ivre qui ai essayé de violer
un bonhomme de neige ou par par la
lecture d'un article sur sur hindouisme
donc c'est ça le problème c'est que j'ai
tendance à farder sorte de liaison entre
des domaines qui ne devrait pas être
relié normalement dans mon coeur donc
les type bourré qui roule à contresens
la politique internationale et et la
mythologie gauloise
moi je vois je vois quelque chose là
dedans ce qui fait que finalement donc
du coup personne ne comprend rien ni aux
paroles ni aux thématiques et c'est
normal
ok
pour peut fonctionner par collage plus
ou moins volontaires pour les thèmes et
c'est vrai pour la musique pour la
musique aussi
je crois que si les progrès travailler
avec des magnétos à bandes j'aurais
j'aurais eu des beaucoup collet découper
raccrocher des bandes bon maintenant
grâce aux machines c'est on peut faire
du collège du découpage de gloubiboulga
d'éléments parfaitement parfaitement
normaux mais qu'on n'aurait pas dû
mélanger ensemble
je ne vous conseille pas ne faites pas
la maison ce sont des spécialistes qui
le font des cascadeurs
ça
l album doit sortir oui il le doit
bon pour les dettes ont arrêté d'en
donner puis sont les rock stars comme
d'habitude ici un album qui va être
relativement relativement très dance
mais bon je sens que au dernier moment
on va pas pouvoir s'empêcher de mettre
deux ou trois morceaux très bourrin pour
rattraper le côté le côté un peu trop
euro dance
je pense que personne ne sera vraiment
choquée par quoi que ce soit là dedans
peut-être que je sera le morceau western
spaghetti qui sera question il est rond
pet
et maintenant au nouveau sujet de la
réaction aux origines du funk la sueur
positive n'est les concerts à la
nouvelle orléans la sarre exposition de
guyancourt propose jusqu'au 17 mars une
rétrospective de l'histoire de la
musique funk de sa naissance jusqu'à ces
mutations
l'exposition qui couvre une quinzaine
d'années revient sur les figures
emblématiques et grands courants
musicaux à travers un parcours
chronologique c'est incontournable
lorsqu'on fait une exposition qui parle
d origine on va on va s'intéresser à
l'histoire et le contexte historique
dans lequel n'est un mouvement musical
donc là effectivement le sphinx et la
voix de james brown s'exprime à travers
femmes entre qui expriment les lames de
tout le peuple noir américain de
l'époque qui était en pleine révolte
contre la ségrégation et qui très peu
connaître de cette époque là donc
effectivement le contexte historique
joue est un facteur qui est
incontournable
les documents tels qu'une place
chronologique les visiteurs peuvent
évoluer parmi cinq espaces thématiques
où figurent entre autres affiches
pochettes de disques d'or musicale de
biographies l'exposition qui se veut
pédagogique et ludique propose même un
peu plus jeunes livrés jeux à
télécharger pour bien oubliée
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
d'aller promener yu-gi-oh clips vidéos
youtube le 16 février le maxi monster
show sera à la merise attrape le même
jour laurent cela vous apprendra à
déclarer votre amour avec iloveyou leçon
un à la maison de la poésie de saint
quentin en yvelines
le 17 février aladin et ses quarante
comédiens seront à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux et du 19 au 23
février vous pourrez voir le cid de
sandrine anglade au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation
culturelle des salles saint-quentinoise
dans le kiosque sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche alors à bientôt
et n'oubliez pas que tous les mardis
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle sur le site www.caf.fr